diversification what I've learned that
works if you're an investor no matter
how much money you've got whether it's
five thousand dollars or 500 million
diversification is what saves you from
disaster having investments in a wide
range of businesses and sectors there's
always something working when something
else isn't so today I can go to bed
tonight knowing that I have one
objective I want to go to bed richer
than I woke up and the only way that's
gonna happen to me is to be invested in
a lot of different things because every
day one thing works while three others
don't but sometimes that's why you get
richer what I find people do is they
fall in love with one idea or one stock
or one investment or their sister comes
to them and says I want to open a
restaurant you should never do that what
you should say is whatever money I've
got I'll never put more than five
percent into one idea I'll never let
myself get caught up in an idea that
ends up being so big to me that if it
fails I get wiped out this is the key to
success no more than 5% of any wanting
idea and no more than 20% in any one
sector for example if you love energy
stocks only 20% max if you love gold
only 20% max you have to have
diversification this is the one thing
that will save your hiney you should
make the assumption when you make an
investment there's some probability
you'll lose it it'll go to zero and
that's why you need to have you know a
reserve like a back-up plan some cash
set aside that if everything blows up
you're okay I find it extraordinary when
people make their first you know
liquidity event and they have some
capital that they blow it all again that
is the biggest mistake you've got to
take a nut even if it stays in cash or
it's a very very liquid safe security to
say that I don't touch it goes back to
what my mother taught me spend the
interest never the principal I mean look
you know I make a lot of crazy
investments I don't touch the principal
you just watched two amazing clips from
Kevin O'Leary take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]